hey guys Lucy here with a quick gamespot
news update for you uncharted force
directors Neil druckmann and Bruce
Straley have taken to the PlayStation
Blog to announce that Nathan Drake's
next adventure a thief's end has been
delayed into spring 2016 uncharted 4 was
scheduled to arrive at some stage in
2015 though Sony had not specified a
final release date the director said the
fulfillment was necessary to ensure the
game matches the high expectations from
fans in a prepared statement they said
since we showed you our first gameplay
reveal of uncharted 40 cents more per
game and story have come together and
it's become clear to us that this game
is much more ambitious than we
originally envisioned after spending so
many years with Nathan Drake he means a
lot to the team and telling the
climactic chapter of his adventures is a
task we don't take lightly this game
deserves every bit of the attention to
detail precise pasting and nuanced
storytelling Naughty Dog is known for so
we've made the difficult choice of
pushing the game's release dates giving
us a few extra months we'll make certain
that uncharted for our concerns not only
meets the team's high standard cut the
high standards that gamers have come to
expect from a naughty Dog's title both
druckmann and straley says they
understood frustrations regarding the
delay but have assured fans that it will
be worth the excruciating wait the team
at Naughty Dog will be head down working
through 2015 making sure that Nathan
Drake story gets the closure it deserves
come spring 2016 you and Nate are in for
one thrilling emotional ride so there we
are are you gutted about the delay or
are you happy that Naughty Dog are
getting the tiny need let me know in the
comments section below and of course
keep your eyes on gamespot for all the
latest on uncharted 4
you